A Turkish chef has the world salivating.
Nusret Gokce was little known outside of Turkey,..
...until Instagram videos of him slicing and salting steak...
...in his own unique way went viral.
The video shows Gokce coiling his arm and drizzling salt off his elbow unto meat...
...in a way that some say is sensual.
It's earned him the nickname "Salt Bae",...
...based on an acronym that means "Before Anyone Else."
Gokce caught fire in January...
...when musician Bruno Mars tweeted an image of the butcher in mid salt.
Since then, the butcher has taken advantage of the spotlight,...
...posting videos of himself slapping, stroking and dancing with meat.
He says he poses for a thousand photos with fans each day.
The viral video has also inspired some copycats like "Cat Bae",...
...a man who prepares food for his cat in similar fashion.
Even athletes are getting in on the move.
Kansas City Chief's tight end Travis Kelce air-sliced...
...and salted imaginary meat during a touchdown celebration at this year's NFL Pro Bowl.